Hey guys, Pete here. today I'm going to go
over the timeline for one of my favorite
shows Dark on Netflix. in Dark everything
is connected and since time travel is
the thing we move through multiple
timelines which can make following
what's happening when very complicated
this two-part video will cover
everything we've seen through seasons 1
& 2 so far and if you haven't watched
the second season yet it will contain
massive spoilers with that out of the
way let's jump right in because there's
a lot to cover the oldest thing we've
seen in Dark so far is the photo of the
group Sic Mundus Creatus Est which we
know was taken on January 8th 1921
according to the back of the photo it
shows Adam older Noah adult Agnes
Nielsen and older Magnus Nielsen which
have all been named so far on screen
also it has who we presume are older
Franziska and older Bartosz to either
side of Magnus which haven't been named
but we know they all travel together
with the stranger aged Jonas at the end
of season 2 there are six more
unidentified people in the photo one of
them could be Erna but beyond that we
don't know who they are and there's a
lot of speculation but we won't really
know until we know before I get into the
rest of this I just want to say as a
native English speaker I'm going to
murder the pronunciations of all of
these names I read through the show as
subtitles every name is pronounced as a
German speaker would say it since I'm
not that the way I read it and the way
it sounds can be two different things
the first date we actually see is June
21st 1921 on that day we meet young Noah
with the character who is possibly older
Bartosz. they're digging the passage in
the caves and then we see Noah kill the
other man because he has lost faith on
the same day we see Adam order older
Noah to find the missing pages of the
notebook on June 23rd of that year two
days later young Jonas arrives from 2053
he's taken to Erna's house which is
like a boarding house and meets young
Agnes
young Noah on June 24th older Noah lies
to Adam about finding the pages from the
notebook young Jonas wakes up at Erna's
and goes to the caves only to find that
they aren't completed yet young Noah
tells him they won't be completed for 32
more years back at the church later both
Noah's take him to meet Adam who
explains that he is actually the older
version of Jonah on June 25th 1921 the
next day Jonas talks with Adam again
Adam explains that the group Sic Mundus
is fighting a war against God which is
time itself Adam shows young Jonas the
machine that they have built in the 1921
timeline and explains that it can
transport him to the exact day he needs
to get to the day before his father
commits suicide we see Jonas leave for
2019 then later in that same day we see
that Adam has the st. Christopher
medallion and older Magnus asks why he
didn't tell young Jonas the truth about
his role in their plan two days later on
June 27th we see older Noah talking to
his younger self about why he needs to
travel and then we see younger Noah
leave for 2020 older Noah shows Adam
that he did find the missing notebook
pages and accuses him of lying to him
and using him he tries to kill Adam but
he can't then Agnes his sister arrives
and kills older Noah instead after that
the older Magnus and presumed older
Franziska send Adam to 2020
through the machine that marks the end
of what we've seen in the 1921 period.
the next year we spend time in is 1953
on November 5th Erik's dead body arrives
in the bunker after being sent there
through the chair from 1986 the middle
aged or the adult aged Helge removes the
body four days later on November 9th he
removes your son's body that ended up
there as well the day after that on
November 10th the two boys bodies are
discovered at the construction site for
the nuclear plant this is the same day
that adult Ulrich travels from 2019 he
sees Agnes and young Tronte
as they are moving to Winden we see them
arrive at the Tiedemann's to rent a room
later Gretchen young Claudia's dog
disappears into the caves Ulrich visits Tannhaus' shop and leaves his jacket
and phone there he overhears that there
have been two bodies found at the
construction site he goes and finds
younger Helge and tries to kill him
leaving what he thinks is his dead body
behind in the bunker the next day
November 11th Ulrich is arrested by Egon
Tiedemann and he does that because he
thinks he killed the two boys young
Helge wakes up inside the bunker older
Claudia visits younger HG Tannhaus
telling him to build the time machine so
things can be set straight
the following day November 12th younger
Helge sees the time portal open and
travels to 1986 through it this is the
last thing we see in 1953 after that
there are a few days we spend in 1954 On
June 22nd older Claudia buries the time
machine so that her younger self will be
able to find it later the next day on
June 23rd younger Helge returns to the
Doppler family home he doesn't speak to
his mother so later she asks older Noah
to help
he asks Helge to read a passage and he
does younger Claudia walks in on her
mother Doris and Agnes together and
later asked younger taranta to pull down
his pants for her older Claudia gives
Agnes a newspaper article that talks
about her murder and tells her to go to
older Noah Agnes tells him that older
Claudia has the missing notebook pages
and tells him to ask Adam if she can
rejoin sic Mundus. Egon goes to visit
Ulrich in his cell because Helga has
returned home and then he gets a visit
from older Claudia who apologizes to him
in his office he doesn't understand who
she is and why she's there older Claudia
then visits younger tan house gives him
his book a journey through time and
tells him that he will have to explain
the time machine to her one day later
older Noah finds older Claudia and kills
her after she tells him that
Adam tells him is a lie he recovers the
missing pages from the triquetra
notebook pages from her and is clearly
upset by what they say we don't see what
they contain but there's something about
his daughter Charlotte in them and we
see that he's upset three days later on
June 26th Egon looks at older Claudia's
body thinking that she is probably Ulrich's
accomplice in Helge's kidnapping he
goes to ask younger Helge about her and
he hears the term white devil later that
same day Hannah arrives from 2020 she
goes looking for Ulrich and that has
her cross paths with Egon they go to the
psychiatric hospital where she
ultimately decides to leave Ulrich
because she thinks he still favors
Katarina and her family over her after
seeing him she appears to decide to stay
in 1954 and there's also a hint of her
coming on to Egon and his office from
there we leave the 1950s and head to
some of the things we learn about in
1986 we don't know exactly when
they happen because we see them in
flashbacks for example we learned that
Tronte and Claudia had been having an
affair we know that at some point older
Noah arrives to become the new priest
and that sometime during the summer the
power plant has an accident on October
9th the adult Helge kidnaps Mads Nielson
nearly a month later on November 4th
Helge travels to 2019 through the cave
on the same day Mads is sent to 2019
using the chair but it kills him and he
arrives dead the next day November 5th
Mikkel arrives from 2019 through the cave
he ends up in the hospital after looking
for his family Egon investigates 33
dead sheep Charlotte finds a dead bird
older Bernd shows Claudia the hidden
radioactive waste that she is about to
take over his position running the power
plant
Helge gives her a copy of a journey
through time as a present for her new
position and we see the author Tannhaus
working on the time machine in his shop
on the same day Erik is
sent to 1953 using the chair but he
doesn't survive the journey either on
November 7th teenage Ulrich is arrested
because Hannah made the false claim that
he raped Katarina to the police stranger
age
Jonas arrives from 2019 to talk to Tannhaus
about time and fixing the time
machine
the next day November 8th younger Jonas
arrives from 2019 through the cave on
November 9th younger Jonas goes back to
2019 without bringing Mikkel with him on
that same day we see Mikkel and young
Hannah meet each other at the hospital
and that's also the same day that Yasin
is transported to 1953 by using the
chair and of course he also dies in that
process two days later on November 11th
Boris Niewald arrives in Winden and
takes on the identity of Alexander
Koehler as he's running away from
possibly committing two murders in
Marburgh younger Hannah sees him dispose
of the real passport and his gun she
goes and takes those and keeps them and
holds on to them throughout the rest of
the timeline younger Hannah also tells
younger Katarina that she thinks that
Regina was probably the false witness
for the rape which Katarina takes on to
be the truth because there's no evidence
the younger Ulrich is released from
prison we see him reunited with Katarina
we see them causing problems for Regina
and then younger Aleksander comes in to
her rescue on that same day we see
Claudia find Gretchen they're reunited
and Gretchen had just arrived from 1953
Helge goes to older Noah he doesn't want
to continue with murdering people but at
the same time he doesn't leave at the
cabin we see him hide from older
Egon who's coming there to interview him
on November 12th Claudia hires younger
Aleksander to work at the power plant he
welds the door between the power plant
and the cave shut stranger Jonas
turns to Tannhaus shop and picks up
the finish time machine older Helge
confronts his younger self and asked him
to stop working for older Noah but Helge
doesn't listen to himself
enos adopts Mikkel younger Jonas arrives
again to save Mikkel and bring him back
but he ends up getting kidnapped by
Helge and older Noah
we see the older Jonas the stranger aged
one visit his younger self in the bunker
and tell him who he is tells him he's
the older version of himself and
explains why he can't let him out of the
bunker that night
older Helge tries to kill his younger
self in a car accident but his younger
self lives and the older version dies
stranger Jonas attempts to destroy the
wormhole but only closes the passage in
the caves at that point the time portal
opens over windin younger Helge and
Jonas touch each other's hands through
it
and that brings younger Helge to 1986
and sends younger Jonas to 2052 in 1987
On June 22nd older Claudia visits her
younger self at her office at the power
plant and tells her who she is she shows
her The Time Machine and the caves and
tell her that she has to stop Adam we
see older Noah and Mikkel meet outside
of the caves older Egon visits Helge at
the psychiatric hospital and he asked
him about Mads disappearance why he
didn't show up for the interview he also
visits older Ulrich in the psych ward for
the first time but he doesn't have any
idea of who he is Hannah and Jonas
arrived they travel with the Machine and
they see Ines and Mikkel together at the
house and later on that same day Claudia
digs up the time machine that her older
version had buried for her in her yard
on the next day June 23rd older Noah
successfully transports younger Helge
to 1953 using the chair Claudia goes to
visit Helge and ask him why he gave her
the book a journey through time he tells
her to never trust Noah older Egon goes
back to visit
Ulrich but at this time he tells him
that he is actually older Nielson
Claudia goes and visits Tannhaus who
explains the bootstrap paradox explains
how his book travelled to him from the
future before he wrote it
older Egon tries to go and talk to
Mikkel about his parents but Ines
won't let him talk to him Egon then goes
to visit Claudia at her office and tells
her about his cancer after that he
returns with Mikkel's photo and shows
that to Ulrich and Ulrich attacks him in
the process Claudia travels to 2020
using the machine and then returns back
on the same day the next day on June
25th
Claudia asks her father to move in with
them she's trying to avoid his death she
meets with Bernd he gives her the
information about the god particle she
takes a sample of that and gives it to
attack to have him analyze it we see in
is at the hospital stealing medication
that she's using to drug Mikkel old Ulrich
breaks out of the hospital and he goes
and meets with Mikkel tries to take him
to the cave in hopes of taking him back
to 2020 Ines ends up calling older Egon
and asked for help older Egon and the
police end up stopping Ulrich from being
able to take Mikkel through the caves
and they arrest him again and take him
back to the psychiatric hospital Magnus
Franziska Martha and Bartosz with younger
Elisabeth all arrived from 2020 from the
back of the police car
old Ulrich sees them by the bus stop but
he's unable to talk to them and then
later that same day they all returned to
2020 On June 26 claudia starts to
record herself discussing what she's
learned
about the development at the plant with
the god particle she ends up going to
Egon's first chemo session with him and
he tells her what he's starting to
realize that time travels real he
explains what's going on with Ulrich and
Mikkel and the caves he wants to act on
this information he wants to call the
police
Claudia tries to get him to stop talking
about it
they end up having an argument he falls
hits his head Claudia is about to call
the paramedics but she decides not to
change anything thinking that she needs
to make this sacrifice because that's
the way things are supposed to go and
that this will ultimately save Regina
younger Jonas after spending what is
about a year learning from older Claudia
arrives at Claudia's house and says that
she has to come with him immediately on
the next day June 27th we see younger
Jonas and Claudia they go to the caves
they get a sample of the waste younger
Jonas and Claudia then used the time
machine to reopen the passage and they
leave together
for 2020 so that's roughly half of the
timeline I'm gonna stop there right
after I finished this editing putting it
together then I'll do a part two that
has everything else in the timeline let
me know in the comments if I have
anything out of place I tried to put
everything together but sometimes it's
confusing considering everything that's
going on let me know what you think of
dark in general what do you think is
gonna happen in season 3 and be sure to
like this video subscribe to my channel
come back to check part 2 and thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon